ist das der erste mensch der kein mensch
ist es ist ein erster eindruck von dem
was bei der technologischen singularität
passiert dann wenn künstliche
intelligenz ki uns überlegen ist gp2
eine künstliche intelligenz die gerade
für schlagzeilen sorgt denn sie schreibt
liest übersetzt und produziert sogar
computercodes alles so wie wir menschen
scheinbar kann dieses programm fast
alles und noch viel mehr die new york
times beschreibt das als zitat gruselig
und ein bisschen angst einflößend ist
das also die erste maschine mit
menschenähnlicher intelligenz krieg zum
science in future hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
der redaktion ix entstanden das
fachmagazin informiert über alle
wegweisenden entwicklungen im it bereich
und am ende könnt ihr euch eine digitale
ausgabe gratis sichern
die euphorie ist groß nicht nur in der
fachwelt das sprachprogramm pc basiert
auf künstlicher intelligenz ki und kann
fast alles egal essays
gebrauchsanweisung rap texte oder
philosophische eindrücke all das hat gps
wie drauf die abkürzung steht für
generated free trade transformative denn
es handelt sich mittlerweile um die
dritte generation dieser ki und es kommt
noch besser die texte die die kg
produziert sind nicht von den texten
einer menschlichen autorin oder eines
menschlichen autors zu unterscheiden
aber nicht nur in sprachen überzeugt
diese ki auch rechenaufgaben kann sie
lösen fragen zu den themen biologie
politik und geschichte beantworten und
sogar computer codes sind drin dahinter
steckt das us amerikanische unternehmen
open air geld kommt unter anderem von
tesla und spacex chef elon musk und reid
hoffman von linkedin und auch microsoft
steuert eine riesige finanzspritze dazu
kurz zur geschichte von open-e die
durchaus spannend ist denn vor fünf
jahren 2015 war das unternehmen
eigentlich als gemeinnütziges projekt an
den start gegangen doch seit dem
vergangenen jahr 2019 vermarktet ein
tochterunternehmen die technologien auch
kommerziell anfang vergangenen jahres
präsentierten die macherinnen
macher das vorgängermodell gp2 doch zur
überraschung vieler wurde der code des
sprach generators nicht veröffentlicht
ganz anders als geplant open
argumentierte dass die möglichkeiten des
programms groß und das risiko eines
missbrauchs enorm sein klar dass das die
aufmerksamkeit des unternehmens noch
einmal ordentlich gepusht hat der bbc
two wurde so nur nach und nach
veröffentlicht mittlerweile gibt es aber
auch die vollversion bei google brain
wurde mit der public domain also der
öffentlichen freien version tensor floh
ein jackpot entwickelt der menschen
imitieren kann also ein gefährliches
potenzial das in einer mächtigen ki
steckt die vorsicht ist also
nachvollziehbar die spekulation rund zum
thema ki wurden durch diese pr strategie
wie böse zungen behaupten jedenfalls
ordentlich angeheizt und auch in den
medien wurde heiß debattiert der
vorsitzende des bundesverbandes jörg
bienert lg petri in einem handelsblatt
artikel als zitat kleine revolution
bezeichnet und sogar die new york times
bezeichnete die künstliche intelligenz
als zitat gruselig demütigend und mehr
als ein bisschen angst einflößen doch
was ist wirklich dran an dem hype
handelt es sich also wirklich um einen
riesigen durchbruch in der
technologiegeschichte und haben wir es
mit gps wie tatsächlich mit der ersten
allgemeinen künstlichen intelligenz zu
tun
klar ist jedenfalls dass es wohl zum
marketing strategie des us unternehmens
gehört immer wieder darauf zu verweisen
welche gefahren von seiten der
künstlichen intelligenz ausgehen um
dieser bedrohung entgegenzuwirken
entwickelt das unternehmen immer
stärkere tools neben der
kommerzialisierung ist das auch das
übergeordnete ziel des ki unternehmens
open die künstliche intelligenz soll dem
wohle der gesamten menschheit und nicht
nur einigen wenigen dient in der
vergangenheit gab es übrigens schon
mehrere aufsehenerregende projekte von
open-e zum beispiel die entwicklung
einer ki die in roboter hände integriert
wurde diese wurden in die lage versetzt
objekte in der hand zu simulieren wie
ein mensch dafür nutzte das
forschungsteam des unternehmens
denselben algorithmus mit dem sie einer
ki auch das spielen von dota also
strategie videospielen beigebracht
hatten kurz zur erklärung die dota trotz
waren menschenähnliche profi
spielerinnen und spielern
tatsächlich überlegen für das
formulieren in der hand
musste die künstliche intelligenz in
einer simulation allerdings fast 100
jahre üben
durch diese projekte hat sich in der
szene also schon einen namen gemacht
doch welche technik steckt wirklich
hinter die ps3 es handelt sich um ein
statistisches sprach modell seine
hauptaufgabe ist es die
wahrscheinlichkeit zu berechnen mit der
ein wort auf ein anderes folgt ein
prinzip das alles andere als neu ist und
nachdem bereits auch schon die text
generatoren der vergangenheit basierten
auf meinem iphone
da gibt es ja auch diese funktion wenn
ich zum beispiel guten 1 tippe schlägt
mir das telefon morgen vor
doch das ist alles noch sehr rudimentär
sehr simpel es gibt einen unterschied
die eltern modelle oder mein iphone
haben eher wenige worte zur verfügung um
das folgende wort vorherzusagen gps hat
er mehr ansätze zur verfügung das sind
knapp 2050 token die diese bei ihrer
prognose berücksichtigt open sind dabei
nicht nur wörter sondern können
satzzeichen aus seien die basis dafür
ist maschinelles lernen mit mehr
schichten künstlichen neuronalen netzen
stichwort die burning wir haben ja hier
bei pixum 20 future schon öfter darüber
berichtet das modell lernt dabei viele
verschiedene zusammenhänge zu erkennen
und schafft sich dadurch ein
multidimensionales koordinatensystem und
dieses neuronale netzwerk ist wirklich
gigantisch nach angaben von opel selbst
besteht es aus 175 milliarden parametern
das sind 100 mal mehr als der vorgänger
und auch das trainingspensum war
gigantisch insgesamt wurden dafür 500 70
gb an text genutzt umgerechnet sind das
achtung rund eine billion börse mit am
start die englischsprachige wikipedia
blogbeiträge leitartikel und und und ein
forschungsteam von google hatte vor drei
jahren eine aufsehenerregende idee
vorgestellt der titel attention ist all
you need demnach sollte ein sprach
modell im besten fall ausschließlich auf
einer sache basieren dem aufmerksamkeits
mechanismus attention mechanischen
modelle werden hierbei darauf trainiert
ihre aufmerksamkeit auf die kombination
bestimmter drucken zu richten
das große ziel hierbei ist es also eine
sogenannte multi hätte tänzen denn neben
der einen aufmerksamkeit funktionen die
sich beispielsweise auf verknüpfungen
von worten konzentriert sind weitere
aufmerksamkeit
funktionen am start so können
beispielsweise auch grammatikalische
strukturen erlernt werden genau wie
konjunktion regeln in der fachsprache
ist also von einer mehrköpfigen
aufmerksamkeit der regel visualisiert
werden diese funktion häufig durch
monster mit mehreren köpfen so werden
dann im besten fall auch verbindung
zwischen entfernten tokens geschaffen
letztendlich kommt es so in den tief
verborgenen schichten des neuronalen
netzes zu einer äußerst hoch
dimensionalen mathematischen
repräsentation von sprache der
entscheidende unterschied zu früheren
neuronalen netzen aber liegt darin dass
die sprache nicht mehr wort für wort
verarbeitet wird zahlreiche berechnungen
können mit hilfe von leistungsstarken
prozessen parallel durchgeführt werden
die google fachleute sprachen bereits
2017 von dem system namens transformer
denn hier wird sprach in einem ersten
schritt in eine mathematische und
abstrakte form transformiert in einem
zweiten schritt wird das dann wieder in
die sprache zurückverwandelt fachleute
bezeichnen auch die petri als ein
transformer in der abkürzung btc der
buchstabe steht der buchstabe b meint
prix trend und damit wird bezug auf das
vorangegangene training genommen
sie steht für generate if der text
generator sammelt also nicht nur infos
aus texten sondern schreibt auch welche
gibt antworten und übersetzt die große
frage hat die ps3 den aufbau von sprache
wirklich verstanden mit all ihren
unlogischen regeln ist die ki
möglicherweise sogar mit dem
menschlichen gehirn vergleichbar oder
kann es dieses sogar übertrumpfen
wissenschaftlerin wissenschaftler sind
nicht zu hundert prozent überzeugt so
unter anderem auch sina paris
professorin für sprachtechnologie und
maschinelles lernen in die ihn an die
fähigkeiten von jp esri sind sehr
beeindruckend aber angesichts der größe
des modells auch nicht überraschend wer
sich etwa diese authentisch wirken
kurzgeschichten genauer anschaut merkt
dass hinter der fassade oft kein
wirklicher sinn steckt ein beispiel um
das zu verdeutlichen die ki wäre wohl
durchaus in der lage informative und
zudem auch unterhaltsame sport
reportagen zu einem fußballspiel zu
schreiben die basis dafür statistiken
doch ein resümee dazu während sieger
hervorgeht würde fehlen und zwar selbst
dann wenn klar wäre das team 12 tore und
team zwei nur ein tor geschossen hätte
verständnis für fußball regeln fehlen
diesen text generator nämlich auch an
logik mangelt dass sie ptsd ebenso fehlt
auch die fähigkeit dazuzulernen
klassenbester auf einem speziellen
gebiet wird es deswegen auch niemals
werden dennoch aber ziemlich gut in
vielen bereichen
demnach handelt es sich bei gitti free
also keineswegs um eine allgemeine
künstliche intelligenz dazu schreibt der
bekannte wissenschaftler landeck und in
einem facebook posting intelligente
maschinen zu entwickeln indem man sprach
modelle hochskaliert ist wie wenn man
flugzeuge baut die möglichst hoch
fliegen können um zum mond zu kommen
heißt also an wirklich tiefes
verständnis von dingen hat die ki nicht
dazu sie nach paris von der universität
jena statistische modelle basieren
letztlich immer nur auf reiner
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung die ki hat
daher gar keine möglichkeit zu verstehen
oder zu interpretieren was sie gelernt
hat der ansatz von pittis und ähnlich
modell wäre ja dass sich die welt
verstehen lässt wenn man ausschließlich
texte dazu liest ist das so oder braucht
es die kommunikation und interaktion mit
anderen menschen und der umwelt die
computer linguistin emily bender und ihr
kollege alexander koller haben eine
klare meinung zu dieser erkenntnis
theoretischen fragestellung sie
schreiben in ihrem papier dass sprach
modelle niemals die wahre bedeutung von
texten verstehen werden denn ihr
training führe sie lediglich dazu die
wahrscheinlichsten muster in einem text
zu lesen hier bei fehle es aber daran
dass auch das kommunikationsziel des
gegenübers verstanden werden müsse
das zeige sich auch am kindlichen
spracherwerb auch hier reicht zuhören
nicht aus ein deutsches kind dass viele
stunden englischsprachiges
fernsehprogramm schauen werde dadurch
kein englisch sprechen können bei all
den talenten bleibt eine weiterhin
wirklich große herausforderung bei der
forschung zur ki gestützten text
generatoren sie sind und bleiben für die
wissenschaft eine blackbox denn wenn wir
ehrlich sind weiß niemand derzeit so
recht wie sie zu ihren ergebnissen kommt
übrigens das gilt für uns menschen auch
vielleicht sind wir gar nicht so hoch
entwickelt wie wir denken und arbeiten
ähnlich ich sag mal simpel wie diese ki
mehr zum thema und anderen umfassend
recherchierten themen aus dem bereich
erfahrt ihr im fachmagazin ix von it
security über big data bis hin zu
embedded systems exklusiv für euch
klicks um zuschauer und zuschauerinnen
gibt es jetzt eine digitale ausgabe
gratis
kriegt dafür einfach auf diesen link
oder unten in die video beschreibung es
lohnt sich auf jeden fall und hier geht
es weiter mit bedroht künstliche
intelligenz die menschheit anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und zwar diesen
kanal bis dahin bleibt dran